welcome to this video maradona I yeah
some guys you meet all over and over
again maybe let's do something else the
Black Knights tango and we will get
probed into an Enzo f2a one of those
slides that I do play the Zurich I
variation okay he's playing with Queen
takes you three that's not happening
that often and they mostly play with we
should be too but I'm going to play this
now this e5 pawn sacrifice let's see if
he is some willing to take the pawn it
seems he is ok 8 Queen B 2 and now I
have forgotten my analysis um and I
remember that it starts with this move a
5
this is really a yep you're getting a
sneak preview now of my book I mean if I
could remember the stuff which is
sometimes a bit difficult especially in
blitz chess um yeah queen bee three is
the key move but i think i'm not sure
about the trade but i think i trade
first check
ideas to invade with Queen c2 and try to
use the better development white has
nothing our to really also queen bee
three attacking before this is why a
five is a very important cornerstone of
blacks concept you have to do that to
weaken this the Queen side and actually
get at the pawn ya know if I would be
cheating I would pull up my file and
look it up but I don't really remember I
think one of my main moosian analysis
was was f3 f3 and giving giving back the
pawn it's really not so easy for white a
player if you look at this and now i'm
now in ennis camp and yeah it's very
sharp can try to try to keep the porn
with be five between before checkers is
a big problem very difficult for what
this is one of the line some way I'm
very confident that like has a good game
in my book check this is always so you
have situational you have spots in a
project like that way you feel like okay
here I'm totally saved yeah this is a
really really good thing or some other
cases where you feel like a candis's may
be shaky and tender in this pawn
sacrifice Lana whoops this was my
Camtasia production software in this
pawn sacrifice line with a 5 i'm very
sick very satisfied that and then
confident that black has a good game it
is really difficult for why to play now
c4 is his weakness yeah it's a bit
unlucky for him that he plays against my
book analysis in in a blitz game um yeah
well I will grab it right check so let's
see he probably has rook h3 trying to
activate it's that way around that night
night rookie for maybe something like
that
maybe King here and on look h3i go rupee
form intending to play rook g-form if he
gives the chick and I also attacking the
edge porn which is not bad okay didn't
think about this so much but definitely
not a bad idea yeah I have to carry a
rookie 6 is not really great yeah maybe
maybe here I a clear this was a good
good way how he played this with the
rook coming to her three I still can't
defend with Ruby for if he gives this
check on g3 and I can set the pawns in
motion okay let's not allow h6 NT i also
have rookie five rook g5 possibly okay
the next thing I should do I should
really get the pawns rolling be 5c 5
now he's falling behind on the clock and
the fantasticks coins this guy seven out
of a dia six drawers six wins two draws
no loss okay it's attacking my my pawn
Sam see 6c 6f between be six or be 6 p-6
maybe better mp6 it's probably better c5
I think rupee 5 is something that I
should do checking the H porn and
allowing group g 5 on the chick
capped still AM Lucas III Ruby five is
sighs good okay that's let's push this I
guess I maybe I should have played rugby
five threatening queen age 3m but the
banya is definitely definitely a
dangerous so I should push it no F for
maybe a is my problem no problem really
i think but i should have I should have
prevented it just to make things a
little bit easier Queen 87 air now Queen
Queen possibly coming over here to to to
be aight i get to check in here it's not
helping very much time morning
hmm it's really not easy how did I do
that yeah I'm really great at this kind
of thing from a from a position of total
control getting this to something that
is not so easy to play at all I know you
will take this bloody pawn on d5 am
great great just great and Queen f5
coming and check taking age five
check totally totally spoiled as him
I check on age 6 ah what the moon hey
this is like this is a total joke right
what did I do hear ya and this is reason
okay the guy has a win against me from
this position air this is quite
unbelievable it is like it's just like
totally lost oh wow that's not easier
but I keep doing this kind of kind of
things it's so bad yeah to be 6 and here
it's really like total control there's
nothing going on I should just play this
bloody move and it's basically over here
threatening this and have control one
area there's no air for and nothing I
mean of course this all winds yeah it is
totally winning but it can't it gets
tricky and it's unnecessary to do that I
can just play rook to e8 here for
example you covering the eighth-ranked
and this is minus 4 oh yeah and now Adam
between f5 was still winning yeah up
here is not easy at all really not check
and of course here i have to go queen to
ga da Queen to GA twice is working at
all they are Queen g8 yeah this is this
is not so great iam and this is quite
funny I can't have this move which sort
of holds the fort but it's just
incredible how can you lose this
position ah ok thanks for watching